moi personnellement ce qui m'a
interpellé c'est cette sorte
d'acharnement contre les musulmans
il y avait un acharnement et parfois et
j'étais gêné mois tissu historienne des
juifs
ça m'a rappelé des périodes où on
s'acharnait voyez comme ça on pouvait
pas aller là on ne pouvait pas rentrer
là et les juges ne devrait pas faire ça
là il y à un acharnement et contre les
musulmans
quand avec ce texte oui vous dites
vraiment à faire la cible du texte oui
j'ai gélules enfin j'ai lu le préambule
du texte c'est clairement dit que il
faut voilà qu'il ya une communauté qui a
si dieuze mans et s'immisce dans le n'a
pas progressé il d'engrais la société
n'y a pas de preuve
[Musique]